I think it's safe to say
there's never been a moment like this one
in all of history.
Of course, it's always safe to say that
because every moment is unique
and can never be reproduced.
But when it comes to AI,
the changes we've seen
in a single generation,
and lately in a single day,
are truly historically novel.
We are the first human beings
to ever experience this.
I want to talk about how we experience it.
AI is changing how we work and create.
It's helping us solve
complex problems in ecology,
urban planning and medicine.
From diagnosing disease
to detecting forest fires,
AI is giving us a new view
of our planet and ourselves.
This comes with challenges.
There are ongoing debates
and open questions about ethics,
power and the relationships
between humans and machines.
Are we at risk of losing
what makes us most human?
How can we preserve and even enhance
the best in ourselves with AI?
I think the answer to these questions
lies in three principles.
Creation, collaboration and care.
We need to nurture
creative relationships with AI.
I've written with AI on several projects
and as an author I've seen firsthand
how AI co-writing can open the mind
with remarkable results.
To test these ideas,
I wrote a novel with GPT-3.
The AI suggested
synchronistic plot twists,
penetrating character arcs
and critical perspectives
I wouldn't have thought of on my own.
Together, we created something
more compelling and imaginative
than either of us would have alone.
So let's co-create with AI.
I love collaborations
because collaborations are more
than the sum of their parts.
For almost 10 years,
I have been bringing artists
and philosophers in
to work with researchers at Google AI
through the Artists and Machine
Intelligence Program.
By collaborating with machines,
we've encouraged a new form of art
that combines and transforms
photography, poetry,
cinema and music
with machine-learning models.
But we've also brought the critical
and creative imaginations of artists
into the process of developing AI.
If we want a world
that preserves and enhances
the best parts of being human,
we need a wide range
of voices and disciplines
present in the process of making AI.
So let's collaborate on making AI.
AI needs a goal.
It needs a North Star.
I believe the highest purpose
for AI is to be healing.
That's why I created the opera
"Song of the Ambassadors,"
working with neuroscientists
to study the effects of music
and human-AI feedback loops.
By integrating AI-generated
brainwave imagery
into the performance,
we were able to propose
new musical and therapeutic approaches.
"Song of the Ambassadors" is offered
as a prototype for a new kind of art
that turns our highest technology
towards collective healing.
So let's care for each other with AI.
These principles are simple.
They might seem obvious,
but the world is changing fast
and AI is complex.
So the point needs to be made clearly.
AI should preserve and enhance
the best parts of being human.
But first, we must imagine new
possibilities and new narratives
for our future together.
The next time you're thinking about
or even thinking with AI,
look for opportunities to create,
collaborate and care.
Thank you.
(Applause)
[A new era for opera beckons]
[Co-created by humans
and artificial intelligence]
[We proudly present a hymn
to nature and existence]
[This is also a neuroscience study]
[It's called]
["Song of the Ambassadors"]
(Applause)